okay why don't we go ahead and get
started welcome everyone to the demise
Thursday conference we are we have a
little bit different of a topic today
but it's it's a very important one and
Joanne Valerius and Karen Eden set this
up and I think it's important for us to
hear the topic today is about disability
awareness ohsu has program in this area
to help people be more aware of work
well with those who have various
disabilities our speaker is in Jacquizz
who's the disability awareness trainer
and community outreach specialist at
ohsu he conducts trainings in this area
which he'll tell us about and he helps
recruit and retain people with
disabilities as well as veterans at ohsu
he's a graduate of the Samford
University Cumberland school of law and
I also saw in his bio that he's worked
some for the Portland Trailblazers
that's correct in the past so I will
turn it over to him and just a reminder
for those who are listening in
cyberspace you can always tweet a
question to using the hashtag demise
comp DMIC e conf so great thank you
thanks very much for that introduction
it's true that I did work for the
Portland Trailblazers I was the shortest
employee for the Trailblazers I worked
there for seven years and I'm glad to be
here now so thanks thanks for coming out
today and I i I'm sorry that pizza had
to be the draw but hopefully you'll have
a good time here today too so disability
awareness is a relatively new thing at
ohsu and as far as I know ohsu is the
only place that does this and and and
what we're supposed to what I'm trying
to do is make people who don't have
disabilities more comfortable
me to people who do have disabilities
the disabilities people with
disabilities at ohsu have said in
surveys and focus groups and through
discussions that they don't feel as
welcome here as they would like at ohsu
because people without disabilities are
often reluctant to talk to people with
disabilities because you're if you don't
have a disability you're afraid of
offending or saying the wrong thing to
the person with a disability and then
you're less likely to engage or interact
I'll tell you a little bit about myself
I am 49 years old now and I got hit by a
car when I was two so having grown up
with a disability that's the first time
this that I'm telling you now at ohsu
that people are reluctant to talk to
people with disabilities so they don't
talk to people with disabilities I'd
never heard that in my 47 years of the
person with a disability but I've heard
it so many times since I've been here
that I believe that it's true and if you
if you in Greta Greta will attest to
this that if you hang out with me for
more than five or six minutes you'll
have plenty of reasons not to talk to me
ok so I'm going to try and be funny and
it'll be a lot funnier if you give me
the mercy left the pity laugh I'm not
above that ok so that so that that's
that's I'm about to go over the ground
rules but I'm just going to go ahead and
jump to that rule number one I'm very
funny so if you think I'm trying to be
funny go ahead and laugh throw that out
there I appreciate that rule number two
since we'll just jump to that you'll go
ahead and jump to that unless it is for
a professional reason and you might have
them you might have a professional
reason to ask don't ask a person about
their disability how they acquired it
how how it manifests whatever it is a
disability is but a part of a person
with a disability in fact it is often a
very small part doesn't define them it
doesn't often guide them see the person
don't see the disability so I say that
to you now as an adult talking to a room
full of adults and I believe that that's
absolutely true so rule number one I'm
funny rule number two don't ask about a
person's disability unless it's for a
professional reason and then rule number
three this is I call a Vegas training
who here has or in cyberspace has been
to Las Vegas
would you like to tell me that what you
did the last time you were in Las Vegas
I attended a health information
technology conference you know what
happens in Vegas stays in Vegas so I
call it a Vegas trainee because this is
a safe room and safe space whatever
never worked in cyberspace before this
is cool so what that means is there are
no bad questions there are no dumb
question if you want to know something
ask please and I will do my very best to
answer it and if I don't know I'm a very
convincing liar and I'll make you
believe I know what I'm talking about
that was a joke not that good a liar so
what we're trying to do today is make
you feel more confident incompetent well
I want to challenge some of your
experiences and expectation and then
also i'm going to talk a little bit
about person first language a person
first language see the person don't see
the disability so it's a person with a
disability it's a person who uses a
wheelchair a person who has one are
there any cyclists in the room okay so
your people to person who rides a bike
really that joke always gets a laugh
that's tough this is a tough crew this
is let's let's jump in so Greta has
sorry I'm running a little bit ahead of
schedule so Greta has handed out a
survey normally I would send that survey
out way well in advance and it's it I
set it up usually via the survey monkey
and it's confidential and it's anonymous
so I don't know any of you and so it's
still going to be confidential and
anonymous so I don't want you to hand
them back in but if you just read along
with the survey as we go through we'll
talk about some things will cover some
areas relative to disability and some of
the questions I'm just going to go ahead
and be honest horribly poorly written I
wrote them I don't know how to write
questions but we'll get to that okay so
let's jump in let's go ahead and jump
into the survey the average person with
a disability so who thinks they know
what this answer is you were relatively
close to first so II right none of the
above so there's no average person right
no average person
no two disabilities are the same there's
no average disability there's no average
person with a disability so person first
language that's that's a good example we
see the person we don't see the
disability cool any questions pretty
simple so far okay question number two
hoon here first before we don't jump
into question number two who knows what
the Americans with Disability Act is I'm
assuming a lot of people do and is there
anybody who doesn't have experience or
knowledge of the ad a yes that's that's
good I'm glad so the Americans with
Disability Act was a landmark
legislation fast 26 years ago signed an
act signed into law by the first
president Bush and what it was supposed
to be and in some ways has been was the
great leveler the great level of the
proverbial playing field for people with
disabilities was going to provide access
who's going to provide opportunity so
it's guaranteed access guaranteed
opportunity all across the board and in
some ways it's been very very successful
so the doorways great curb cut great
Braille almost everywhere great so it's
it's inclusive it's supposed to it's
supposed to provide that opportunity
that Avenue for people to access stuff
and and again some ways it's been great
and in some ways it's been more than a
little disappointing and we're going to
talk a little bit about that right now
so in the three ways sorry the four ways
that are the biggest letdowns one would
be education so a lot of very old
buildings in the world of Education and
very hearts with people with
disabilities to navigate those campuses
consequently they don't public housing
housing is a big issue it's a huge issue
and it's going to be the biggest issue
as the baby boomers at age up and more
and more of them become people with
disabilities the third one is healthcare
so it's supposed to provide equal access
to healthcare but guess what it doesn't
and to be fair it really can't because
there's so many types of disabilities
and so many different needs of people
and again no average person with a
disability that we see that people will
have unique needs and unique challenges
with access as that as it goes along but
what we're here to talk to you about
today mainly is employment so going back
to the Earl
part about people with disabilities
working at ohsu so we did a survey
allowed by law for the first time ever
two years ago and it asked people at
ohsu to voluntarily self disclose if in
fact they had a disability because the
feds want to track that the feds expect
all federal contractors to have seven
percent employment rate for people with
disabilities across all job levels all
job levels in all job categories except
the very highly technical that we get a
pass on that but we're still expected to
be seven percent institution wide and
seven percent at all job category from
that survey and we had more than
eighty-five percent of the ohsu
employees took who took the survey
participated in the survey eighty-five
percent we had a three point four
percent rate of people with disabilities
and feds want that to be seven so we've
got a long way to go now I think and
people with whom I work think and
believe also that the rate is actually
probably higher than 3.4 percent but
there are a lot of reasons why people
are uncomfortable daya disclosing that
they have a disability there's a there's
a huge stigma attached right and and
part of this part of the purpose of this
training is that we're going to
hopefully talk about that stigma and and
and start working away it's a huge
stigma it's a huge problem we're not
going to get there through one trainee
but we're going to get out we're going
to start on that path okay so that's the
Americans with Disabilities Act now the
thing that the Americans with Disability
Act gave us that we never had before was
the comp the clause the reasonable
accommodation so a reasonable
accommodation if I am qualified to do a
job but i need some accommodation to
make me able to do that job from an
access point or from a safety point then
the employer is obligated to do that
right I don't want I don't want any
special treatment the law doesn't give
me special treatment but it would give
me a reasonable accommodation and the
best reasonable accommodation I could
think of let's say I work in a kitchen
and I chopped carrot that's my job and
if the workstation is up here and I'm
chopping carrots what's the message
don't eat the carrots okay I thought
that was funnier than it was I preach
okay so a reasonable accommodation would
give me a workspace where I would be
less likely to chop my fingers off okay
so just and that would be reasonable
because giving me a workspace is
probably just finding another table or
stealing one from here then I'm in the
kitchen I'm working everything's great
but employers have traditionally felt
like a reasonable accommodation is going
to be unreasonably expensive
consequently people with disabilities
have a much lower employment rate than
people without disability and it in fact
this increased the unemployment rate for
people with disabilities has increased
since the passing of the ad a okay and I
would like to say at this point that in
fact people with disabilities like me
are often bargain hires because we
provide our own shares okay there you go
I got you though that one alright so
that's a long way to talk about question
two who knows what the answer the
question two is how does the ad a
defined disability looking for a guess
at any anybody a brave person a a is
right did anybody a is absolutely right
so it's a statutory where it's a
statutory question and you see some
statutory language there so it's a
physical or mental impairment that
substantially limits one or more major
life activity now to be honest I'm
asking for honesty did anybody pick C
did anybody think that C might be the
answer okay now there's one reason why
people self-identify as disabled did I
know if I've only ever heard of one do
you know what it is parking okay good we
get the good parking rockstar parking
okay but that is actually in all the
trainings that I've done I've done over
a hundred at ohsu in the last year and a
half people often pixie that's the most
often picked answer to this question
crowd at number three please so what
percentage of the US population has a
disability who wants to take you yes sir
is it mission of limiting and is there a
definition of major life activity there
are there are many definitions of major
life activities and there's a legal
definition and there's a medical
definition and it's generally though
common sense and we're going to get into
a little bit about what this got what a
disability might be so my disability I
hit by a car when I was to spinal cord
injury can't walk
that's a major life activity it could be
the hidden disability like some sort of
congestive heart failure depression
diabetes things like that so those
things that limit you from having the
opportunity to fully participate in life
that would be a general limitation of a
major life activity good okay cool
question number three what percentage of
the US population has a disability yell
it out that's right nineteen percent
you're alright nineteen percent one out
of every five let's call it twenty
percent one out of every five what's
that mean that means 56 million people
in this country alone worldwide its
twenty one percent okay that's 1.2
billion people what's that mean we're
taking over and you're welcome to join
so but if you think about that now like
I said before the percentage rate of
employees at ohsu who just self disclose
that they have a disability
three-point-four percent the general
population twenty percent now some of
the people in that twenty percent are
too young or too old to work but we
would expect I think statistically and I
don't know anything about statistics
other than that statistically we should
expect to see more than 3.4 percent okay
yes sir that three four percent come
from medical records or just a survey of
Hoover the boards that's a survey of who
report we don't we can't we my
department at the furman of action equal
opportunity we don't access medical
records for this purposes and the feds
don't want that so I can't force you to
disclose and and in fact I could say
that I don't have a disability in my in
my job I encourage I would absolutely
never say that because a it's a it's
dishonest be I can't hide this and see
I'm not ashamed of it now want people to
know and I and when I'm at when I am
recruiting people to ohsu I always
encourage them to disclose because
that's the way we're going to fight the
stigma we're going to fight it from many
different directions but that is one way
where people don't disclose because it
should be no penalty
for a reasonable accommodation purposes
absolutely absolutely you just need to
have a dot you need to have a documented
disability and then you need to work
with your department or your professor
or whomever to get those accommodation
did you press the question button
disability is underreported yeah has
that been quantified let me so let me
say this yes in that is the census has
in some magical formula determined that
it's twenty nineteen percent of this
population and then twenty one percent
because there's no way that we could
that anybody could collect that data
specifically so quantified in that way I
would say yes that makes them ok so I'm
specifically asking about underreporting
so if we have three point four percent
yeah I'm here that could indicate two
things one that there's some sort of
hiring bias and something like that or
two that there's a huge stigma cig matic
pressure yep that force is under
reporting and I'm wondering about the
how one would differentiate or start to
look at that that's a great question and
I will do my very best to get that back
to you and so my contact information is
going to be at the end of this and I
don't have that answer to be honest and
I won't like yes sir what about those
people that are you pressing about yeah
what about those people that would fall
under the ad age disability definition
of someone who's disabled but they don't
really identify themselves as being
disabled what would you mean some people
might not report it because they feel
their disability isn't actually a
disability and it's not really that big
of a concern for them well I I think
that that that happens and and that's
their right I think that that just that
just propagates the stigma that just
supports the stigma and I think that
that that creates more of a problem than
it helps now I know individually on a
case-by-case basis not for me to say but
I think that under reporting and not
admitting is ultimately defeating the
purpose of defeating
any other question love these questions
that's great okay let's move on most
people with disabilities prefer to be
helped in performing daily life
activities true or false false okay so
let me ask you this and I'm I'm just
going to ask this as a blanket question
if I could and I want to be clear that I
can't but if I could and there were no
strings attached higher for you for
everyone individually a cook a cleaner
show for somebody to do whatever
gardening housecleaning whatever is
there anybody here no strings attached
who wouldn't let me do that for them
okay and speaking on behalf of all
people with disabilities because I have
the microphone good joke speaking on
behalf of all people with disabilities I
would absolutely prefer that too I
absolutely love it I would love that
that would be awesome to have somebody
do that for me because then I could do
stuff I want to do not stuff I have to
do but what we don't want and what I'm
encouraging you from an ohsu perspective
is I don't want people to force help on
me without asking me if I need help
oftentimes I will absolutely need help
and will gladly take the help but what I
don't ever want is somebody to assume
that I need to help and do something for
me without talking to and that that can
be very upsetting and that's the purpose
of this question is to think about why
I'm here to make ohsu a more welcoming
place for disability to encourage people
to talk to people with disabilities
rather than forcing help on someone and
that could be as easy as opening the
door right always nice for somebody to
open the door for somebody else I love
that but what I don't like is to
somebody to grab the door and open it
and not say anything hey it looks like
you're struggling can I help you with
that door could I help get that door for
you carrying coffee you're carrying a
beer whatever it is not carrying a beer
at work but if you're caring of carrying
coffee into a door somebody come up to
me and say hey can I get the door for
you that's great I love that and what I
always say is no you know what let me
get the door for you and then I reach
out like I'm going to open the door and
I hit the actuator
because it's a it's a shallow gesture by
a shallow person okay any questions any
questions about that poop question five
so service animals come up a lot and in
discussions at ohsu I hear complaints
and worries about service animals so
there's okay to pet a service animal
without asking permission and why is
that they're working they're working
okay that's great so we know that dogs
like this dog here can be service animal
there's one other type of animal that
can be a service animal under the
Americans with Disability Act and
adopted by the state of Oregon does
anybody know what that animal is it is
very much a miniature horse that's
exactly right points to you okay and
miniature horses act as seeing I animals
for people who are blind okay and
apparently they're at CHH all the time
down the hill I've never seen one but
anyway that's cool so let me ask you
this I'm coming back to you okay so
let's say you're you tomorrow you come
in you work tomorrow use your student
work tomorrow whatever you're going to
be here tomorrow you come in tomorrow
and you look up ahead to building your
report to and you see if man you need to
holding the leash and the leash is
attached to a chicken and the chicken
has a vest and the vest and the vest has
letters it's a service animal on it what
would you do cut the chicken that's the
first I like it and okay so you don't
have to say you take a selfie but I know
you would right but what else but what
else would you do you would say you're
say you're skeptical you should be right
and so then what would you do press that
button what would you do okay here's
what I want you to do I want you to tell
everybody you know everybody at ohsu
that you you know who you work with that
there's a person with a service chicken
why seriously because we don't want
anybody to be scared we don't want any
of you I who's scared of chickens I am
but let's say it's not a chicken let's
say it's a sock that's sorry a snake
wearing a sausage it's a sock let's say
it's a snake wearing a sock and the sock
spells out service animal on it because
it's poor
Portland that could happen that happens
that happens right what would you do
then do like snakes anybody all right
leave kitty so it's it's a person with a
snake and a lot of people including me
are afraid of snakes we don't want
anybody to feel uncomfortable anybody to
be scared whether their co-worker a
patient a visitor call or whatever so
don't do anything about the person other
than call patient services or public
safety they know how to deal with that
we can again and they will but you don't
need to be a hero you can ask if that's
a service animal but what are they going
to say right right that's what that's
what the sock says service animal okay
so so we know we know what do we know
you got to ask and you really shouldn't
ask cuz they're working right to pet
right and then and then we know it's a
dog or it's a miniature horse and if
it's not it's not a service animal but
it could be a therapy animal right and
how do you know if an animal is a
therapy animal though each issue sorry
Justin okay they they have where's my
tag they have name tags they have ohsu
issued IDs as do I somewhere they have
ohsu issued IDs and that's how you can
tell if it's as if it's a therapy animal
okay now there's one other type of
animal that's often confused with a
therapy animal or a service animal
that's called a companion animal okay
containing animal just three letter word
that is a containing animal pet pet cat
is a companion animal pet though was
what i was looking for small points to
you so pets are not allowed at ohsu okay
and how do you tell if it's a companion
animal and not and not a service animal
well no service animals service animals
don't always have a service animal
jacket or vest or a sock on them they
don't right so there's no but containing
animal won't have an ohsu issued ID it
may be an animal other than a dog or
miniature horse but it could be a dog
and not all dogs are trained to be
service animal and how do you tell if an
animal's not a service animal
you could ask is that a service animal
they're probably going to say it is
though but you kill you could ask they
might tell you the truth but the other
way you can tell is if the dog is making
noise making a mess making somebody feel
uncomfortable service animals don't do
that but pets do that containing animals
do that and again we don't want anybody
to have a bad time at ohsu we don't want
anybody to cause anybody else to have a
bad time of the age issue so if you have
questions don't be a hero and call
public safety ok any questions on to
question six ok so the question on the
survey that I hand it out do the terms
disabled person and person with a
disability meaning the same thing true
or false they do mean the same thing to
her fault all somebody say fall somebody
say true ok so let me tell you I told
you that I'm 49 years old and I gotta
hit by a car when I was two and I i
don't know if i told you but i have a
spinal cord injury and when i was too i
had a spinal cord injury and I'm 49 now
and I still have a spinal cord injury
right so my condition hasn't changed and
those 47 years felda spinal cord injury
but when i first got hit I went to a
Shriners Hospital for crippled children
so I was a [ __ ] and then after I was
a [ __ ] I was a [ __ ] and I was
handicapped and then I was handi-capable
and I was physically challenged and
differently able and now I i heard
recently i experienced a disability i
don't know what that means but i'm also
now at ohsu a person with a disability
right so the way people have referred to
me has changed many many many times
since I've been a person with a
disability but my condition has it so
they've grown they have learned those
phrases and they still use those phrases
i saw in a no h su publication today
somebody with a disability described as
disabled person we want to do that we
want to see the person first right so if
somebody says disabled person that gives
me an opportunity to engage them in that
versation that way you don't want to see
the disability we don't want to limit a
person I don't know what a person is
capable of in any way but especially
based on their physical condition right
I can't see a person in a wheelchair and
say well that person can't climb Mount
Everest I don't know if they can but and
I don't want to make that judge and
that's that's an adjustment that's a
that's a ridiculous example but I use it
as a point in saying that people with
disabilities have climbed Mount Everest
right so don't limit the person with the
word see the person first give them that
give them that expansive opportunity any
questions somebody might ask the
question is that true for all people
with disabilities not right so the the
the culture for people who are deaf
disagree with that and they don't like
phrase they don't mind the phrase deaf
person it's part of the culture it's
something that a lot of them are
comfortable with and that's cool that's
on to them but at ohsu in our bylaws we
say we're a person first culture we see
the person until we're told differently
if a person who is deaf wants to be
called a deaf person more power to them
but that's up to them okay you don't get
to make that big important any questions
tick question 7 speaking to a person who
is deaf or hard of hearing you should
speak louder and slower true and false
true or false false who said that very
brave did you press the button it's
false false okay that's great why
because usually they can hear you just
fine if they you don't know if they have
cochlear implants or how bad their
deafness is or if they can read lips
right what about slower should you speak
slower them know what because they can
read lips just fine usually if they're
reading lips or in slowing down can
actually really screw them up that's
exactly right right so what we say what
we say is that people with disabilities
are experts in their abilities they know
what works for them so you speak to a
person as you would speak to anybody
right and then if they can't hear you
they may ask you to speak louder
they may ask you to use sign language or
they may ask you to do something that
works for them better than just speaking
that's on them they have that power give
them that opportunity cool and and and
you're absolutely right about don't
speak slower to a person who reads lips
because that will upset their cadence
and ability to read lips right and
that's also true for people who use sign
language various types just particularly
American Sign Language people who use
American Sign Language prefer not to be
spoken to slower because that will also
upset their understanding of what you're
saying any questions okay question 8
most disabilities are visible and
obvious to others true or false false
okay right so most disabilities are in
fact hidden and what are some examples
not yet what are some examples of hidden
disabilities psychiat press the button
psychiatric disorder psychiatric
disorders right can anybody else think
of some I told I said some before so so
congestive heart failure right
depression psychiatric disorder diabetes
cancer HIV aids up a number so please so
here is an example of but a few of the
hidden disabilities there are many many
many many more of those than we've
listed we don't have time to go over all
of them so what's the what's the what's
the message there can't judge a book by
its cover you can't tell if a person has
a disability or not so you treat the
people as you would have them treat you
some call that the Golden Rule I don't
have permission to use that phrase
copyrighted was a joke okay I feel like
I've lost the crowd okay any question
any questions about that we really we
really like that we really like that
well go over there okay on yes yes yes
where did socio-economic issues come
into the disability list so being
homeless or being impoverished could
limit your ability to participate
in major activities that's a good that's
a good question so does that count as a
disability being being homeless it does
not it does not the things that may
cause a person to be homeless might
count as a disability so that's not
actually going to qualify being homeless
as that if that makes sense a little bit
so so go ahead well I mean it seems
somewhat arbitrary on you know whether
you know if somebody is very very low
economic status and in the u.s. they
can't participate in life's activities
there so why do we why do we limit it to
this list and not include social issues
so say so so so Alli fact a life
activity would be walking a life
activity would be seeing hearing
participating fully life not an
opportunity to play sports but say an
opportunity something that might limit
you from doing those things from
breathing from seeing from active living
it without being depressed something
like that those count is disability but
life activities so just to be clear a
life activity that can you give me an
example of a life activity that you
might be talking about here well if you
if you have almost no income your
ability to participate in a lot of
activities in this country is going to
be extremely limited butbutbut
activities as in social activities like
going to a dance or eating out right
educate so there are way there are ways
around that that you're there are huge
barriers social barriers pay-to-play all
that sort of stuff that that's a that's
a societal construct that's not a
disability per se as it relates to a
person's oppor opportunity and ability
are not the same thing so an opportunity
to participate if you have to pay is
that's a that's a barrier but not being
able to raise your heart rate because
you'll have a heart attack is
the type of major life activity that
we're talking about here that make sense
I'll agree to disagree we can move on
okay cool appreciate that yes sir yeah
so I don't think my things oh this this
list that you have up here include
that's the twenty percent that you
referred to earlier yep question ma'am
um well just in terms for what he was
speaking to you before your and about
the homeless I think this is relating
more to physical disabilities versus
socio-economic well it is really in two
more two more two physical disabilities
but these can manifest physically these
hidden disabilities can manifest
physically so there's a there's a
disability biz there's a difference
between my type of physical disability
and say lactose intolerance that one Wow
okay but now that's not to say that all
lactose intolerance is is a disability
but it can be such that it's so severe
that it would be a disability so there
are various degrees in this you're not
always automatically going to be counted
as disability as a person with a
disability if you have a mild asthma
maybe but it could be so severe that it
would count that yes ma'am
it is largely defined not not not
entirely defined but largely defined as
the is a specific life activity a major
life activity defined in the ABA it
absolutely is defined to a point but
it's not totally inclusive of all major
like that good cool any other questions
question that's a great question thank
you for us minute yes sir back to you so
once again getting back to like the
statistics that you're citing or earlier
and yeah the 20 you were saying earlier
twenty percent of americans are
qualifies being disabled yes is that
same definition use in the ad a for
instance yet lactose intolerance but
medically medically it is legally it may
not be and there's a little bit of
there's a little bit of so when we say
we say a disability often these things
are largely permanent my disability is
permanent you can also be temporarily
disabled a person with a temporary
disability say you have a knee injury or
a broken arm or something like that that
could count medically as a disability it
wouldn't necessarily count if let's say
you had a temporary disability that
required you to get a temporary
reasonable accommodation for you to do
your work you'd be one of us but just
not for long so okay ten minutes left ok
question ten nine to nine ok so a
horribly poorly written question here's
but if you see this person you shake his
hand you meet this person you meet a
person like this with a double umber you
do you shake his hand automatically if
he offers it right you press the button
I'm good at the button pressing if he
offers it if he offer if he offers his a
hand so you follow that you follow the
person's lead right you don't
automatically put yourself in a position
to make a person feel uncomfortable but
if they want to shake hand you shake it
cool and this is a better description
with the picture than it is written so
please don't read the written word ok on
to question 10 when speaking to a person
who uses in
interpreter always speak directly to the
person not to the interpreter true what
if you can't understand what the person
saying and so so so let's say so we say
interpreter here but let's change the
fact pattern a bit let's say it's a it's
a an A or an assistant so let's say I'm
not able to push my wheelchair but I
have an assistant who's pushing my
wheelchair for me and I have a condition
that prohibits me from being clearly
understood when I think so i may have a
some type of condition or impediment
that makes it difficult to understand
still speak to me or do you speak to the
person who has experience and in talking
with me and can understand what I'm
saying always always talk to the person
absolutely always talk to the person so
there are things that you can do when
you meet somebody that are that may be
difficult to understand whether they
have an assistant or not so let's say
that you that I don't speak clearly and
you want to talk to me that if you want
to talk to me and put yourself in a
position to understand what I'm saying
and to be understood by me or by someone
else absolutely cool to say hey can we
go over to a place where it's a little
quieter or to a place where you can more
visibly be seen so that you can
participate in that communication in a
better way absolutely cool to say don't
understand I don't think I understand
what you're saying but just to be sure
did you in fact say that you would like
to buy me a box of donuts so you could
ask a question to try and get to that
understanding absolutely cool to do that
so that gives the person a chance to say
no I don't want to buy you a box of
doughnuts again as people often do and
then I would say oh so you would like me
to buy you a box of donuts and then you
would answer in the affirmative because
who doesn't like donuts so ask ask those
questions give that give yourself a
chance to be understood give them a
chance to be understood now as a bonus
question if you see me on campus and you
want to talk to me hopefully that
happens at some point do you stand and
talk to me or do you stoop or crouch to
get on my eye level who thinks that you
should crouch
assuming that you'd want to talk to me
who thinks that you should stand who
thinks that they don't want to talk to
me because there are not everybody's
plane so here's here's the rule the rule
is the the conventionally understood
rule and accepted rule is that we need
to be on eye level right so you need to
crop the conventional rule I don't agree
with that rule my rule is i want you to
be comfortable because if you're not
comfortable when we're talking we're not
going to talk for a while and I think
that we should be friends so I want you
to be comfortable if you're comfortable
crouching crouch if you're comfortable
standing stand if you're comfortable
saying hey you get to sit I want to sit
too let's go over there where there was
a chair so we can talk that's absolutely
cool but put yourself in a position to
relate to the first in a good way ok any
questions about that so I want to share
with you a couple of things that happen
to note to me at ohsu and then I want to
talk about those a little bit so before
we do that I want you to consider your
childhood for a second remember the
first time that you saw a person with a
disability not a family member but
somebody outside who you've never seen
before and you might have been with a
family member or guardian or a parent or
somebody who says to you hey hey hey
don't look don't stare at that person
don't stare and stare don't stare okay
so that anybody had that experience and
they were a kid right a few of you too
so the parents will say often don't
stare okay now so think about that for a
second while I tell you these scenarios
last November not last November to
November's ago I had a meeting in Mac
hall across the way there it was in the
afternoon it was in the cafeteria we the
only people in the cafeteria when the
meeting was over when touted the hall is
the only person in the hall I was going
a particular direction down the hall up
the hall whatever it was somebody came
around the corner reading a book and
this person had their head down as they
were walking along reading the book and
we're walking in opposite directions
were passing and just as we're passing
this person while reading the book jumps
back
puts her back against the wall and walks
the rest of the way down the hallway
ever once looked up there was no eye
contact there was no acknowledges okay
that actually happened and I'll tell you
that as a person who's been in a
wheelchair for 47 years that happens all
the time that happened to me last week
at safeway people get out of my way
they've never run into somebody
purposely but people always think I'm
done it so they get out of the way okay
now that doesn't bother me 47 years I've
had tons of experience but imagine that
if you work in a place where you might
encounter a person where you were a
student at a place where you might
encounter a person who's in a wheelchair
or a mobility device for the first time
in their life and that happened how
would that person feel and you guess any
guesses
they would feel I think they would feel
pretty crummy I think they would feel
pretty bad okay so that happened on a
Wednesday the very next day was a
Thursday oddly enough and I was in the
building next door plaza cafe and I had
to go all the way down to the [ __ ] and
I wanted to see if unlike the day before
i could make eye contact with somebody
because i couldn't the day before I'd
struck out I'd lost my magic and I was a
little bit panicked wanted to see if I
could make eye contact so as I was going
towards the tram by the plaza cafe I was
striking out and I was afraid that I had
in fact lost my night I couldn't make
eye contact with anybody because
everybody had their phone out and
everybody had their head down and they
were looking at their phone so not one
to give up easily I continued on walking
up the hall I saw a guy with his back to
the windows a beautifully sunny November
day which never happens as you know but
it was Christine it was crystal clear
lovely blue sky guys got his back to the
window he's also sitting in a hospital
issued wheelchair not a cool titanium
wheelchair with red folks like I have it
was a horribly awful plastic wheelchair
he was wearing a hospital gown and a
bathrobe and I put those all those
doctors together to determine that this
guy might in fact be a patient and
thought he was depressed and here's why
I thought he was depressed because he
was sitting with his back to the window
on this perfectly blue sunny day and he
was looking at his feet so I thought
right I'm going to make eye contact with
this guy so as I was walking towards him
I did something that I don't normally
like to do I stared at it just walking
towards him and I was staring at him and
I know that's rude but this was for
science so forgive me so as I was
getting closer and closer to this guy I
think he sensed that somebody was
looking at so he started looking around
he's looking around he's looking around
and we lock eyes we make eye contact in
a second we make eye contact I nodded at
him and I
wow he did something I'll never forget
he SAT up straighter and he smiled back
in so just for that second that guy may
have forgotten about his troubles but
either way he felt better about himself
he felt welcomed at ohsu and I tell you
the stories these stories because I
encourage you to when you have that
opportunity to make that eye contact to
make that acknowledgement to say hi if
it's appropriate because it will go away
it'll go a long way to making ohsu a
more welcoming place for everybody but
specifically for people with disability
and going back to the earlier slide
about people with disability disability
you just never know if a person has a
disability but making that contact
making that acknowledgement can go a
long way to making somebody feel better
and the weird thing was that when that
person smiled at me and I was having a
great day right it was sunny outside I
his new blue shirt on plenty of copy
everything was good but when he smiled
at me I felt better about myself right
and that's a good thing to do okay so I
told you early that rule number one is
don't ask about a person with how they
don't ask a person how they acquire
their disability I said that to you as
an adult from as an adult to a room full
of adults I absolutely believe that to
be true but if you have kids if you know
kids if you work with kids I want them
to be told it's okay to ask and it's
okay to look I dont still don't want us
there but I wanted to look I don't want
people to be afraid I don't want kids to
grow up being afraid of people with
disabilities and I want them to grow up
being confident and comfortable talking
to people with disability and I know
this is a this is a research-based
institution so I'm going to provide you
evidence that this is a good thing to do
I have a nine-year-old daughter and when
I go to visit my nine-year-old daughter
at school and this is particularly true
when she was younger kids will often and
especially when she was younger would
almost always come up to me and say hey
mr. J buying a wheelchair
what's wrong with your back why don't
your legs work whatever it was it ask me
those questions and I would always
answer them and I still do always answer
them honestly and as in-depth as they
want to go usually the last five six
seven questions whatever it is and then
they get to that point where they have
everything that they need to know and
then they follow up with another
question anybody know what that question
is the question yes can we write in your
wheelchair oh good guess though the
question is at school when that happens
is how much longer is recess right so
they get what they need to know from me
and then they move on and we're cool
next time they say me see me sorry the
next time they see me they say hey mr. J
how you doing what's going on if they
see me as an ice cream store it's do you
really need more ice cream good let's be
serious kids going to be me so that's
basically that's basically the train
right so see the person don't see the
disability don't assume a person can't
do something or doesn't need help get to
know the person talk to the person ask
the questions Gallants the assumption be
engaging be friendly may go let's let's
make ohsu the place that we all know
that it can be and bite include
including people with disabilities
that's one way that we can get there
thanks for letting me crash your party
and I'm happy to answer any questions if
you have any questions yes how the
environment has changed in years during
left for 22 years in the terms of
people's opinion except and disability
and building that's a great question how
has how has the equation except
acceptance changed and life change in it
so I grew up in a very very small town
in southern Indiana that's where I was
injured so that in the late 60s and I
was the only person in that town who
used a wheelchair and there was no
access to anything I had to crawl
upstairs this is one of those terrible
stories I had to crawl upstairs to go to
school three flights of stairs in high
school to get to high school and to
crawl down stairs and there was no
accessible bathroom and I couldn't use
my wheelchair in the school
because there's no way to get the
wheelchair up so things have changed a
lot things have changed a lot people are
still afraid of disability I think
they're there the assumption is that a
person with a disability is in fact
unable to do a lot of stuff and and and
I think that that's still true I think
it's less true than it was but there's
still still some trepidations that were
reluctant some fear I think so things
have improved a lot but they got a long
way to go free for patients require the
use of a wheelchair outside of being a
patient in the hospital yep what's the
hospital policy with regards to like
being required to use Hospital issued
wheelchairs are being like so you know
you use a hospital the purse the patient
will use a hospital issued wheelchair
until they leave the premises and then
they have to provide their own
wheelchair that make sense that answer
your question absolutely can they bring
their personal wheelchair to the
hospital absolutely so I never go
anywhere without my cool titanium
wheelchair with red spoke so if I were a
patient here I would get to use this
here absolutely good question any other
questions yes ma'am push the button I
rang the max a lot and there's a
gentleman there who has a vision
impairment and he uses a white cane here
sometimes he can't figure out where an
empty seat is how do I not offend him by
saying how to direct him to a seat what
you say sir what can I can I give you
some assistance to find out see you just
that you just asked you're asking that
question you're not trying to be rude
right your upcoming you're asking that
question from a good place now that's
not to say that people always accept
that but i think if you come from a good
place and asking that question then
you've done all that you can sir is
there something I can do to help you
find that seat or sir there to see two
steps to your left something like that
you direct them and it's often cool to
ask the person with the visual that with
a person who's visually is a visual
impairment say is there some way that I
can help guide you whether it be by
leading bleeding with the person
their elbow or whatever and you ask them
what works best for you but know what
works best for them so you give them the
power to tell you what works good good
question but it's I don't think I don't
think that that's offensive if it's
coming from a good place any other
questions yes sir um early in your
presentation you mentioned that most
institutions should try to fill have
seven percent disabled persons or
personal is great employed yep and that
most of those institutions have about
three percent how they don't know that's
that's us I don't know I don't know
anybody else I know no one fit in seven
so have they have we also looked at how
many people have applied who have a
disability we try we try to track that
so here's what happened here so and well
and that's so we don't we don't right
now track that we are getting the
software that will allow us to track
that so what happens if I know a person
who has a disability is applying for a
job at ohsu what I do and I'm allowed to
do this as I will ask the person if
they're comfortable with me disclosing
to a recruiter or to a hiring manager
that this person has a disability I
never asked what the disability is I
don't want to know I never forward that
particular message but I will say to the
recruiter the hiring manager this person
has applied for this job on this date
and this person has a disability and as
a federal contractor we are required to
have an aspirational hiring goal please
consider give this person extra
consideration stuff I guess I found that
interesting because to me that if you
knew whether you had only like three
percent or a small number applying or
you would know what kind of problem you
are dealing with the terms of well so so
that it's it's it's the it's the age-old
it's the age-old problem of people being
too busy with too many responsibilities
to do enough tracking so that we can
collect that good data so recruiter a
recruiter may be responsible for ten
positions at one time and keeping track
of that data has been difficult to
software hopefully that we're adding
will make that better but
it will be a challenge that will always
be a child good question any other
questions okay well great thank you all
very much and so grete handed out a
evaluation form if I could beg of you
please to fill out that evaluation form
and to Leonard can I have people turn it
into you and then I and you can enter
opposite to me so please don't put your
name on it it's supposed to be anonymous
and all feedback is greatly appreciated
and I think she passed them out did
every we didn't get the evaluation form
okay well okay great i will do that then
that's great okay great well thank you